Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight,
the American dream continues.
I led a program
for gang leaders.
How many others are there
out there like this?
‐Nothing.
‐Nothing?
We've sold over $1 million
in sales.
‐Whoa!
‐What?
Next year, $10 million.
How the beep
is that possible?
I want somebody
who also believes in me.
Nobody is going to give you
$400,000 for 10%.
‐Can we take a minute?
‐Your valuation is stupid.
Do you see any problem with
that before I eviscerate you?
You don't have an order,
Disha.
What do you mean
by an order?
There's a reason why
that storefront was empty.
Guys,
they're freaking me out.
You're trying to talk yourself
out of it is what's going on.
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is an apparel brand
to make men feel more confident.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks. Thanks for
meeting up with me today.
My name is Jonathan Diersing,
and my company's Rounderbum.
I'm here today asking
for $150,000
in exchange for 10%
of my company.
Sharks, there's nothing better
than walking out the front door
full of confidence,
ready to conquer the world.
Whether you have a board meeting
that day,
a date,
or a red‐carpet event,
regardless of the occasion,
when you look good,
you feel good.
And, Sharks, who doesn't want
to look and feel good
every day and everywhere?
I mean, how many times
do you find yourself
putting on a pair of jeans
that just don't fit right?
Maybe they're too big
or too loose or too flat.
Have you ever wished,
while getting ready
in front of the mirror,
that you had a little bit more
back here or even up here?
[ Laughter ]
Sharks, for centuries,
women have had their ways
of enhancing
the shape of their body.
Men, on the other hand,
have been stuck with
what they've got, or don't got.
It's time to say goodbye
to those saggy jeans
and hello to sexy.
[ Gasps ]
Oh, my. They're twins.
Introducing Rounderbum.
[ Laughter ]
Rounderbum
is a body‐shaping technology
that is redefining
the underwear market,
giving each person
a boost in confidence
that they've been looking for.
Rounderbum offers different
underwear technologies
to help you look
and feel amazing
before you walk out
that front door.
[ Chuckles ]
"Underwear technologies."
Not only do we offer
your traditional
compression shapewear,
we go one step further.
We enhance the shape
of your body from head to toe,
giving you more lift
and volume
in the areas
that you desire most,
helping you look and feel
amazing.
Our model here is wearing
our padded trunk,
along with
our padded muscle shirt.
Now, Sharks,
I know you guys might not need
any help with confidence,
but our customers love
the way they look and feel
when they wear Rounderbum.
And more importantly, they're
made for comfort and discretion.
They're invisible
under clothing,
and they feel natural
to the touch.
Sharks, we're not just changing
the way that people look.
We are changing the way
that people live.
So who's with me?
Who's ready to turn this square
world into a Rounder world?
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐All right.
We'll now pass out some samples
for you guys to see,
but you can see
the before‐and‐after look.
Herjavec: Oh, my Lord.
[ Laughter ]
My goodness.
You can really tell
the difference.
Right?
‐Yeah.
‐Thanks.
So, they'll be passing out
some samples
that we want to show you.
The padded trunk, you can
actually pull out the pad
that you can feel
and see for yourself.
‐Thank you.
‐Oh, my goodness.
The cool thing about this pad is
that it's made with a zero edge,
so the whole purpose of this
is to not have a lining
underneath your clothes
to make it invisible to the eye.
Jonathan, why do men
want bigger butts?
Everybody appreciates
the way they look,
and everybody
wants to look better.
I mean, not everybody has
the time to go to the gym.
Women wear shapers.
Men wear shapers now.
There's Manx.
What's the difference between
this and Spanx for men?
So, Spanx is more
of a compression.
What is the price point
of this?
He's not compression.
He's addition.
Diersing: $25.
‐How much?
‐$25.
‐$25. That's a lot.
‐Is that a lot?
We find it
pretty competitive.
So, what are your sales?
I mean, that's ‐‐
What are your sales?
So, we launched our website
in May 2015,
and to now, we've sold
over $1 million in sales.
‐Whoa!
‐What?!
I never thought
you would say that.
But that's more than two years.
That's more than two years.
Are you kidding me?
What have you done
in the last 12 months?
In the last 12 months,
we did $700,000.
‐What?
‐Is that at a store or online?
‐This is online only.
‐Only.
So we have
our online retail store,
and then Amazon
is a major customer of ours.
I'm amazed
you're selling that much.
How are people
even finding you?
Our advertising.
We're trying to get as much good
advertising as possible.
Where are you advertising?
Facebook's, like,
our number one.
You did $700,000 in sales.
You should be making money
hand over foot.
You should be crushing it.
What's your profit on that?
Our net is about 25% to 35%.
‐Wow.
‐Okay. So you're making $200K.
But that means you took home
$200K last year, right?
Yes.
So what do you need
the money for?
We need the money because,
as of now,
it's pretty much me
working here.
I want to hire
an amazing marketing team
to help me create
some viral videos,
create awareness, so that people
invest more in Facebook.
The more we invest,
we're seeing more return.
And also, we recently did ‐‐
we got a brick‐and‐mortar store
in West Hollywood, California,
on a prime location.
‐Oh, there we go.
‐John, you're killing it online.
What made you wake up
one day and say,
"I want to go
brick‐and‐mortar"?
Well, our prices
at our fulfillment center
are through the roof,
and I was like, "We got to find
out how to cut our costs.
So I'm gonna make half of it
a fulfillment center
and the other half
a place that people can go
and feel our product."
So it's cheaper for you
to hire somebody,
fulfill
out of the back of the store,
and then have the front
part be a store itself.
Diersing: Totally.
You know, in a real retail
location in West Hollywood
is cheaper
than a little warehouse?
‐Oh, yeah.
‐I know. I'm surprised.
Come on. You want to go into one
of the worst businesses, retail?
There's a reason why
that storefront was empty.
For us, if I can save
$3 an order, I'm saving that.
Why don't we try
and value your business
on this year's
coming sales?
So, this year, we anticipate
on hitting $1 million.
Next year, we anticipate
on hitting $2.7 million.
You're already doing sales.
Why are you trying to go
so fast?
Well, I have to acknowledge
that this wasn't
what I went to school for.
I went to school
for neuroscience at USC.
Cuban and Greiner:
Neuroscience?
So, my mom
has multiple sclerosis,
so I went to school
trying to figure out
if I wanted to be
the doctor to help her,
and going there, I was like,
"I don't have the drive
that these other students do,"
but I couldn't afford
to change my major,
'cause I paid
for school myself.
So I just finished it,
and then, after school,
I just started hustling,
started sales jobs,
and then, this was something
I was doing at the same time
because I was hoping
that I can do something
with my life to make my mom ‐‐
And then, on your own, you're
gonna do over a million dollars,
and you don't think
that you have the knowledge.
That's what you're saying?
On your own, you're about to do
over $1 million.
I didn't ‐‐
Yeah, well, as of now,
this is what we're creating
ourself.
I need to realize that
I'm not a professional marketer.
I really need ‐‐
‐Neither was I.
You've done a really good job,
though.
You've done a great job.
Diersing: Thank you.
I have a company
called Titan.
They make, uh...
‐Yeah, I know.
...compression,
and it's weighted vests.
Yes.
When I wear it
and other people wear it,
it looks very similar
to this,
but it's more, right?
A lot more?
Oh, yeah. But that's more
for working out, right?
That's not something you wear
and then...
It's to work out,
and then I can explain,
"Hey, I'm just working out,"
right?
It causes a negative,
I think, question
because people think I'm trying
to bulk up for no reason.
Mm‐hmm.
And I guess I just don't
understand it, so I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you, Daymond.
I think
it's very interesting.
I like it.
I'll give you $150,000,
but I want a royalty ‐‐
2 bucks off every unit ‐‐
that's a dollar
for each cheek ‐‐ and...
[ Laughter ]
...I'll take 5% equity.
The royalty ends
when I double my money.
I get $300,000 out, done,
and then I'm your partner
with the 5% equity I've got.
Okay. Now, Mr. Wonderful,
what can you offer me?
Can you help me get into the
major retailers of the country?
The great news about getting
a Shark as a partner is,
everybody returns
any Shark's call,
so I'll do that for you.
Mm‐hmm.
You tell me which retailers
you want to talk to,
and I'll call them,
but I'm not sure retail's
a great idea for you right now.
Okay.
Because you own
that inventory problem.
The better strategy
is to continue to pour gasoline
on your online sales
the way you've done it.
I'll simplify things,
right?
I've got to believe
in a product.
I go commando.
I'm out.
Hey, thank you.
I totally get it.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec:
I got to change seats.
Thank you.
I never knew that,
but thank you.
Too much information,
Mark.
Greiner: TMI.
I think
what you're doing is great.
It feels real, it looks real,
you're marketing it correctly.
Even though
you had no background,
you figured it out.
I think you're doing great
just by yourself.
I don't think you need
an investment from me,
so I'm out.
Thank you so much.
Jonathan, you've done a great
job, but I can't get behind 10%.
♪♪
I'll give you the $150,000
for 20%.
That's my offer.
You don't want
to give up 20%.
I mean, that's ridiculous.
Robert, would you consider
doing it for 15%?
No. No.
I think
it's a lot of work.
It is a lot of work,
but I want somebody
who also believes in me, too,
so I think that meeting halfway
is more than fair.
My business partner
I spoke to,
we're not interested
in a royalty deal.
We want somebody who's
gonna be with it long‐term.
I'm a 5% shareholder
when it's over.
The point
with Robert's deal is,
it's not a dollar a cheek,
it's 10% per cheek.
Mm‐hmm.
He is asking for 20%
of your company today.
That is greedy and savage.
Get me back $300,000.
He's still talking.
Talking, talking, talking.
I feel very comfortable
with my deal.
‐Okay. So, then if ‐‐ if ‐‐
‐$150,000, 20%.
Don't do it, Jonathan.
You're lowering my valuation,
so if you're willing
to double your investment,
I'd be willing
to go with that deal.
Very clever, but I'm not willing
to do that today.
$150,000, 20%.
I know what we can do.
‐Tough decision.
Do you want this
as the face of your product?
♪♪
Cuban: What are you gonna do,
Jonathan?
What are you gonna do?
♪♪
I really love your deal,
Mr. Wonderful,
and I accept your offer.
‐Whoo!
‐Yes!
‐Congrats, Kevin.
‐[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
‐Thank you, man.
‐What are you doing?
Spank him on the butt.
‐Yeah, thank you.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Guys, thank you very much.
‐He's got padding.
Thank you all so much.
Congrats, Jonathan.
Diersing: I didn't want to do
a royalty deal,
but Robert's deal was gonna
end up costing me a lot more.
And the fact that I can still
have a Shark on my side
and give up less equity
in my company
was a win‐win situation
for all of us.
I've never heard a deal
here being negotiated in cheeks.
Your name is no longer
"Mr. Wonderful."
It's "Cheeks."
Mr. Cheeks to you.
I like it, I like it.
Narrator: Next up is
what the entrepreneurs believe
is the next hero
of cleaning tools.
♪♪
Hi!
My name's Kevin Williams.
And I'm Glenn Archer.
We're from Alexandria, Virginia.
We're asking for $500,000
in exchange for 10%
of our company, Brush Hero.
So, I'm
an avid mountain‐biker.
And I'm an adventurer, but more
importantly, I'm an F‐16 pilot.
As car geeks and riders...
And pilots.
...we were looking for a
solution to our own problems ‐‐
how to keep
our machines clean.
We were tired of jamming up
and scraping our knuckles
trying to clean our rides,
using brushes
and sponges and chemicals.
It simply didn't work.
Sharks, say goodbye to the zero
and hello to the Brush Hero.
The Brush Hero is an innovative
yet simple water‐powered brush.
It cleans with amazing force,
powered by water pressure
alone ‐‐
no batteries required.
It's fun and easy to use.
All you need to do
is connect the Brush Hero
to a low‐pressure water source,
like a garden hose.
Check it out, Sharks.
This thing puts out
amazing torque.
I can press on it
really hard,
grab it with my hand, even,
or jam it into tight spaces,
and it just
keeps scrubbing.
We developed the Brush Hero
with car, motorcycle,
and bike detailing in mind,
but we quickly realized
that you can Brush Hero
virtually anything.
Use it on rain gutters,
barbecues, patio furniture...
or the propeller
on your Cessna.
What do you say, Sharks?
Be a hero and help us
fight the war on muck.
So, the best way
to actually get an idea
of what this thing can do
is to Brush Hero something.
‐Yeah.
‐That'll be me.
♪♪
All right. I'd recommend
that you kind of grab it
and feel the force
that it puts out.
The idea is you can
really reach in there.
Daymond, I have a special place
for that for you.
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: Okay. Here.
Do you want to try?
‐Yeah.
‐Thank you.
Why is it slowing down,
Kevin?
Doesn't spin very fast,
but it spins
with quite amount of torque.
Got it.
Glenn, are you often
cleaning your own F‐16?
Actually,
I'm a former fighter pilot.
I stopped flying in 1999.
But people do use it
to clean their airplanes,
'cause you can only use
a low‐pressure water system
on an airplane.
What do you sell it for?
The basic configuration
is $34.99.
And, Kevin, is that
the basic configuration up there
that I see?
‐Yes.
‐That package?
‐That package is correct.
‐Can we see your packaging?
‐Sure, of course.
‐What's the cost?
‐Right now, it's $6.50.
‐Wow, that's a great margin.
‐Wow.
‐That's great.
‐That is a great price.
But we can get the margins down
a lot further than that.
We can get it under $4
with a little more help.
‐Really?
‐Yes, sir.
O'Leary: What are you gonna sell
this year?
We're gonna do about $3 million
in total sales this year.
What are you gonna make
on that?
on the $3 million?
Well, we should end up making
about $300,000 to $400,000.
Greiner:
Where are you selling them?
We're doing most of
our direct‐response
advertising on Facebook.
And you're spending how much
a day on your Facebook ads?
Well, to date, we've spent
$460,000 on advertising,
totally, across ‐‐
And that generated
how much in digital sales?
$1.5 million.
You're asking me to pay
a 20 multiple for a brush.
Do you see any problem with
that before I eviscerate you?
A lot of it has to do with
our projections for next year.
What's the number
for next year?
Next year, $10 million.
‐Oh.
‐Okay. Well, look,
I'm gonna reverse engineer
this for you.
This is a free service.
I won't charge for it.
Which means you're getting
exactly what you paid for it.
O'Leary:
No, no, you're getting ‐‐
I'm gonna tell you
what you're worth.
I think, if you went into
the private‐equity world,
they would value your company
around seven times,
about $1.7 million,
which means
if you want to get $500,000,
you're gonna have to give up
about 33%.
Are you willing to give up 33%
of your company? Yes or no?
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but they question
the valuation
of Kevin and Glenn's rotating
brush company, Brush Hero.
Are you willing to give up
33% of your company?
Yes or no?
I don't think we would.
So I predict
you won't get a deal.
How many others are there out
there like this?
‐As far as competitors?
‐Yeah.
‐Nothing.
‐Nothing?
Any device that turns water
in a low‐pressure environment
usually can't produce
any torque.
Kevin, Glenn,
I'm not a big cleaning guy.
You know, I have Kevin to clean
my motorcycle and my car.
Just not something
that I get excited about.
I'm out.
Guys, it's tough for me
to know the distinction
between how much pressure
and what the mechanism is,
but it's also why you've had
to spend so much on marketing.
You're kind of in a race,
because you want to get it out
there as quickly as possible
before
other people replicate you.
That is tough
from a long‐term basis,
and with that amount of money
for only 10%,
it's got to really be
a long‐term benefit
that's gonna continue
to grow.
I'm not sure that'll happen,
so for those reasons, I'm out.
Okay.
I looked at it and said,
"You're worth $1.7 million."
I asked a crucial question,
would you give up 1/3,
and you said no.
So you actually predefined
your destiny with me.
I'm out because
your valuation is stupid.
♪♪
‐Stupid? Wow.
‐Stupid.
Herjavec:
The beauty of Kevin is, you
always know where you stands.
Lori?
‐I'm giving you great advice.
Lori, Daymond?
John: Yeah, guys,
the valuation is really crazy.
But I love to be part of
companies that I can help.
I'm interested
in the retail side.
I see it going outdoors,
as well.
You know, great relationship
with the Bass Pros of the world
and the Cabela's of the world.
But I know
I have to go to work.
I'll give you the $500,000
for 25%.
♪♪
Thank goodness
it wasn't 1/3, right?
[ Laughter ]
Greiner:
Well, here's how I see it.
It's highly demonstrable.
I think you need the QVC.
I think we could do
extremely well.
I'm going to give you
an offer.
John:
And it's gonna be a bloodsucker.
I'm gonna ‐‐ [ Laughs ]
I'm gonna give you $500,000,
also at 25%.
That's what I was gonna do.
‐Ooh!
He said it first, but that's
what was in my head.
Herjavec: Wow.
Would you consider, um...
half a million at 20%?
♪♪
No.
I think 25%
is right and fair,
because I'm gonna have to do
a lot of work.
You know, my Simply Fit board,
in one year,
we did $170 million in sales.
No exaggeration.
I would have the same type
of game plan for your product,
what I did with them.
Daymond, are you willing
to go down to 20%?
Are you willing to go to 20%,
Daymond?
[ Sighs ]
Don't do that.
What do you want?
‐Guys...
‐Ooh, I like this.
‐They need the cash.
They need the cash.
‐Do you want to go cheaper,
or do you want to go
with what's best for you?
Lori, stop groveling.
Let me answer.
‐Enough, enough.
What's the best partner
for you?
Herjavec: Lori...
I'm gonna stay at 25%.
‐Okay.
‐Ooh.
Can we take a minute?
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐Thank you.
You know what happens
when you leave the Tank.
Bad things.
‐Nothing good. Nothing good.
Archer:
So, what do you think?
Lori,
they have products like this.
‐They have products like that?
‐There are products out there?
‐With a hose.
‐No way.
Yeah.
They said their patent
is on more torque,
but there are products that spin
that you can buy right now.
The exact same product?
My car‐detailer guy
has them.
♪♪
Hey, guys, is this the only
product that spins with water,
or the oscillation
is stronger?
I'd actually like
to say a quick thing.
No, no, no.
No, one second.
There's other products
out there
that push water through
and they spin.
There are brushes that
flow water through them.
And they turn, as well?
Herjavec: I'm not saying
their's isn't better,
but it's not the only one.
You can't find them
anywhere.
There aren't
very many of them, but...
I didn't know there was
other products out like that,
so I'm out.
♪♪
You're out now. Lori?
That's what happens
when you go outside ‐‐
I get more information.
‐So, you know ‐‐
Guys,
they're freaking me out.
♪♪
Williams: We would love
to work with you, Lori.
Well,
they're freaking me out,
telling me that
there's all sorts of other ones
out there on the market
like this.
But there really aren't.
Is it ‐‐
They exist,
but they're not even ‐‐
I don't want to say
they're not in the same league.
Not in the same class.
But are you saying now
that there are other ones
that oscillate?
‐Not a water‐powered brush.
‐Not a flow‐through water brush.
All I want to say is, look what
happens when you leave the Tank.
Guys, I'm changing my offer.
Oh, that's painful.
I'll give you $250,000 as a loan
at 7% interest
and an additional $250,000
for 25% equity.
Yes! Yes!
That thing just rotated on you.
But we were ready to accept
your previous offer.
You guys are asking
for half a million dollars
that my fellow Sharks
have all just said
there's other products
out there on the market,
so that concerns me.
I think this is a little bit
too much, obviously.
When you ask
for a half a million dollars,
it is a big risk to me.
I know the work
I'd have to put in.
I put my heart and soul
into all I do.
It's just, um,
it's probably too much for us.
[ Whispering ]
I'm sticking to my guns.
Decide soon.
You saw what happened
last time when you left.
They're gonna try
to talk me out of it again.
No, no, nobody's tried
to talk you out of it.
You're realizing the truth
about this.
You're trying to talk yourself
out of it is what's going on.
I think there's a big
opportunity here.
I really do.
This, uh ‐‐
This seems like it would be
right in your wheelhouse.
I think we have a difference
of opinion, but, uh...
There's friction between
the two of you now?
You guys, if you can't decide,
I'm gonna go out.
I think
that we're gonna have to pass.
‐Oh!
‐Didn't see that coming.
Thank you for everything.
You guys have been great.
Congrats on a great company,
guys.
‐All right, guys.
‐Thank you so much.
Lori. Did you hear the whiz?
Vww!
That's you dodging
that bullet.
It doesn't matter that there
are other brushes out there.
This is
a really good solution.
And at the end of the day,
we want a Brush Hero
on every hose in America.
Every hose in the world.
World!
♪♪
Corcoran: I'm hosting my annual
entrepreneur retreat
in New York City this year,
and I've decided
to try something new.
I picked six of my favorite
"Shark Tank" companies
and asked them
to swap businesses
for a few days
before the retreat
so that we could all learn
from each other
and share information.
I asked Cousins Maine Lobster
to swap with Tom + Chee,
Grace & Lace
to swap with Pipcorn,
and Daisy Cakes
to swap with Raising Wild.
Welcome to the Big Apple,
and welcome to my home.
I can't wait to hear
how it all turned out.
Cousins Maine Lobster is now
franchising our restaurants.
And we knew that Tom + Chee
were experts.
We had a lot to learn
with marketing ‐‐
when you walk into a restaurant,
what message you're told.
I think I learned a little bit
about some tough love.
Just hearing them talking on
the phone to different vendors,
they are a lot more aggressive
when they talk.
We avoid confrontation,
and I don't think that's
necessarily a good thing.
These young girls know
so much about social media.
Social media will be a great
platform for Daisy Cakes
to get the word out
about our cakes of the month.
She allowed us to take a peek
into how organized she is.
Daisy Cakes runs
on a very strict schedule,
and we realized that
we need to follow her footsteps.
They have so many items.
So it was really interesting
to see
how they manage
that inventory.
It really lit a fire for us
to launch more regularly
and really get people excited
about new flavors of Pipcorn.
These guys
are in over 3,500 stores.
And we really need our product
in more retail stores.
And what better to learn it
from than Pipcorn?
I'm so happy with the way this
whole thing has gone,
so let's get upstairs
and celebrate.
People came away with not just
one lesson but many lessons
they're bringing back
to their business,
and you know what else?
They're really
a tight‐knit group now.
Really close friends.
Great to have you here.
I love you all.
‐We love you!
Cheers!
Total sales when I invested
in these six businesses
was a little over $3 million.
Since making deals with me
on "Shark Tank,"
total sales
are now over $123 million.
That's the most famous building
right there.
Sabin: We partnered with Barbara
five years ago.
She is still challenging us.
It just shows
the type of person she is,
the type of mentor she is,
and the type of friend
that she is.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a product
for savvy online shoppers.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Disha,
and I'm from Columbus, Ohio.
My company is Savy.
I'm seeking $100,000
in exchange for a
10% equity stake in my startup.
I love shopping online.
And you know,
as a teenager on a budget,
you can't ‐‐
you can't, uh, negotiate
on prices at all, right?
So, Savy...
helps you...
set your price.
[ Exhales ]
‐You're doing great.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Don't worry. Don't worry.
This is only the biggest moment
of your life.
‐Ah...
‐Yeah.
Savy democratizes the online
shopping experience
so you, the customer, can set
the price you're willing to pay
for the items that you love.
I used to save links
to my favorite products
so I could
check back up on them
and see if they had dropped
in price
so I could go back
and buy them.
But whenever I would go back,
they'd either be sold out
or out of my size.
I thought there had to be
a better way.
Enter Savy.
‐Ta‐da!
Say you're shopping online
at your favorite boutique,
and you see this dress
that you absolutely love.
You check its price
and realize it's way more
than you're willing to pay.
In most scenarios,
that business loses the sale.
But if your favorite boutique
is partnered with Savy,
you, the customer,
get to enter the price
that you're willing to pay,
and Savy will e‐mail you
if it reaches
your desired price point.
You get a sweet deal,
and Savy helps businesses
by providing really critical
information about price.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to help shoppers
discover their savvy style
at an even savvier price?
‐Good job.
Did I hear you say
you're a teenager?
‐I just turned 20. Yeah.
‐Congratulations.
If I'm a retailer
and I want
to actually sell an item,
can I just decide
to drop my price
and hit the bid
of somebody,
or do they exist
anonymously to me?
I don't know who they are.
‐Yeah, so ‐‐
‐What's the answer?
The businesses themselves
get the prices entered
and the e‐mails,
but if an item actually goes
on a discount
and it reaches
that price point,
the customer will
automatically get an e‐mail.
To Kevin's point,
he's saying
if I just say
I want to spend $50 instead,
the retailer could say, "All
right, I'll sell it for $50."
‐Yeah.
‐They could.
They could reach out.
But the real main way
of it working is
instead of you having to
search every single week
to see if it's gone down...
‐Mm‐hmm.
...you say, "I want to pay
$80 instead of $100,"
and if they discount it,
they'll let you know,
and then the e‐mail goes.
‐Exactly.
How many users
do you have now?
So, I have 1,000 stores
that are using Savy currently
in the last ‐‐
But how many users
have registered with you?
2,000.
How are you adding
your consumers,
and how are you adding
the stores?
[ Chuckles ] I'm getting them
through social media.
So, I realized that stores
convert a lot better
on Instagram DMs
and Facebook Messenger.
So I created an army
of Instagram bots.
I coded them out.
‐You coded the bots?
‐Yeah.
‐Oh, that's very cool.
What's your background?
So, I caught
the entrepreneurial bug
between my junior and senior
year of high school.
I went to a program at MIT
called
the Launch Summer Program,
and I decided to start my first
startup called TacBoard.
And what did TacBoard do?
So, it was basically, like,
an aggregated shopping site
where you could name your price
for items that you liked.
So, we pulled products from
a bunch of different retailers
and housed them
on one site.
Is that operating?
No, so, I was 18 at the time.
The coders
that built out TacBoard,
they didn't build it scalably
'cause they were
high‐school coders.
I knew TacBoard
wasn't the right product.
So I let go
of my entire team.
I was living at home.
I had foregone my scholarship
to the University of Michigan
for engineering,
and I was devastated.
I was by myself,
and my startup was dead.
Wait, wait, say that again.
You had a scholarship
to Michigan.
‐Yeah.
‐What happened to it?
I had deferred my admission
because I thought that TacBoard
was gonna keep sustaining.
So you decided
not to do engineering
because TacBoard would be
your boat that you'd ride.
Your thing.
‐Yeah. Yeah.
‐What did you do next?
I lived with my parents up
until recently.
I moved to Wilmington,
North Carolina.
I'm finally out of the house.
Why did you move
to North Carolina?
I led a program
for gang leaders.
♪♪
‐You've been what?
‐You what?
[ Chuckles ]
Greiner: You've been leading
gang leaders?
Yeah.
Yeah, so, basically,
there was a six‐week
entrepreneurial boot camp
to test whether they were
disciplined and motivated enough
to start a brewery
of their own.
‐A brewery?
‐Gang members?
‐A gang‐member br‐‐
‐Isn't that ‐‐
‐Let's keep peeling this onion.
Is this a community organization
that's saying, "Hey,
we want to stop violence
and give people
other opportunities"?
Yeah, yeah, and I wanted
to learn how to lead.
I wanted to learn how to
influence and work with people
and manage people.
Do you have any interest
in going back to school?
‐Not right now. No.
‐I'm out.
‐Oh.
‐I'm gonna tell you exactly why.
‐Okay.
‐If you know how to code,
you've extended
your ability some,
but there's a whole world
that you know nothing about
that you're trying to pick up
in bits and pieces.
I do want to go to school
eventually, just not right now.
It's your choice, right?
Look, when I was in college,
I couldn't even tell you
how many businesses I had.
But I learned.
‐Yeah.
O'Leary: However, there are
many entrepreneurs that
proved that an education is
not a prerequisite for success.
And maybe you're one of them.
‐That's true.
Your story's interesting,
though.
But it's a very strange,
eclectic journey.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐And I'm an investor.
I'm looking at it saying, "Maybe
it's a little early for you.
Maybe you got to get a little
discipline in your life."
After making
an assessment of risk,
do I want to give you
$100,000?
My answer's no.
I'm out.
‐Okay.
‐So, when I was your age,
I came home and I told my dad
I'm gonna drop out of university
'cause I was too smart.
I didn't need to go
to school.
He looked at me and he said,
[Russian accent] "I love you.
Kill you,
bury body in backyard."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] I was the
first person in my entire family
that ever went to university.
‐Yeah.
If you're not gonna go
to school,
I need you to be
fanatically obsessive
about what you're doing.
‐Oh, I completely am.
‐And you're not.
You're not.
I'm out.
Okay.
We've talked a lot about
what you've done in the past.
Yeah. Yeah.
But we don't know so much
about Savy today.
Yeah. Mm‐hmm.
How long have you
been doing Savy?
Savy's been going on
for about a year.
What have you sold?
I have not sold anything yet.
I have four verbal commitments
from large retailers
which will potentially give me
$1 million revenue by 2018.
So, if you haven't sold
anything yet...
Wow.
...$100,000 for 10% ‐‐
Why do you feel
that you're worth that?
Because of
these verbal commitments.
But a verbal commitment
isn't anything to an investor.
You don't have an order,
Disha.
What do you mean by
an order?
Until they give you an actual
deal on paper with money...
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐...it means nothing.
It's just a conversation.
Greiner:
You know, the problem is
we have to know tangibly
what are we investing in.
Mm‐hmm.
I don't feel like this
is fully fleshed out yet.
I'm out.
John: So, I think that
there are a lot of other
products out in the market
where I can find pricing
not the same exact way as yours.
I just don't see ‐‐
‐Wait, wait, wait.
If the person's price point
is actually met,
there's an 87% chance
that they'll actually convert
into a paying customer.
But you haven't ‐‐ you haven't
converted any just yet.
‐No, no, I have.
‐So you can't give us an 87‐‐
Have you taken a dollar
from a person?
I haven't taken a dollar because
I'm collecting this data.
So you have not ‐‐ You're not
getting that part of it.
Everybody's gonna tell you
your baby's beautiful,
but until they take
a hard‐earned dollar
out of their pocket
to give it to you,
it means nothing.
It's just their opinion.
I'm out.
♪♪
‐Good luck.
‐Thanks.
‐Thank you.
I'm pretty angry.
I don't think they took the time
to listen.
I feel like
they're missing out.
I don't ‐‐
I don't need them.
Cuban:
I'm mad at her.
She just did
a really poor job...
So?
...of explaining
what her differentiation was.
So, if ‐‐ if she's having
a hard time in the Shark Tank,
what happens
in the real world?
Yeah,
but it's nothing special.
The whole thing reminded me
of Bambi and Godzilla.
No, Kevin,
she's 20 years old.
Ohh, come on.
‐She's not ready yet.
‐She's not ready.
That's all it is.
Narrator: Next up is a product
for extreme wine lovers.
♪♪
Hi!
My name is Jennifer Sullivan.
And my name
is Randy Rothfus.
And we are the creators
of the Guzzle Buddy!
The Guzzle Buddy!
[ Laughs ]
We are here today
seeking $400,000...
Wow.
...for a 10% stake
in our company.
‐Damn, that's a lot of guzzling.
‐Wow!
‐I know how this is gonna end!
‐Whoo‐hoo!
‐Yeah!
‐Guzzle!
Now, Sharks,
let me ask you a question.
Have you ever
judged somebody for drinking
straight from the bottle?
No, 'cause I was always
drinking from the bottle.
‐No.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Well, that ‐‐
‐Th‐at's what's up! [ Laughs ]
Well, we have the solution
to all your drinking problems.
Introducing the Guzzle Buddy
wine‐bottle glass.
It turns your bottle
into your glass.
‐What do you mean?
‐Oh, and don't worry.
We have one for you soda
and beer lovers, too.
‐You simply plug it...
‐...and chug it.
‐Ohh!
‐Cheers!
‐My God!
‐Ohh!
‐Ahh.
It makes drinking
from the bottle "classy."
Okay, now,
our silicone sleeve
fits in most bottles of beer
and wine.
And it fits in most bottles
of soda and hard cider.
It's made from a strong
borosilicate glass.
It's dishwasher‐safe,
and it's freezer‐safe!
So go ahead. Feel free to chill
it, plug it, and chug it.
Now, who's ready to try drinking
from the bottle with class?
‐Let's try it!
‐Yeah, yeah.
‐Come on! Come on.
‐I'll do the wine.
I'll do the wine.
‐Oh, it's Mad Dog 20/20!
‐Whoa!
‐What?!
‐Thank you.
♪♪
All: Cheers!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐You just drink.
‐There you go.
How did you come up with
this crazy idea?
‐Yeah.
‐Oh, my gosh.
Well, one night I was sitting
at home watching an old sitcom,
and they had a product
similar to this.
And so I thought
Randy and I love our wine,
so I knew we needed
this product.
But I looked everywhere for it
and couldn't find it.
No way!
And so we thought, "Well,
let's find a manufacturer.
Let's go out."
And through trial and error,
we came up with this product.
You heard the catcalls when
you said $400,000 for 10%.
‐Yes.
‐If it's a $4 million value...
Yes.
Four ‐‐ Let that roll
of my lips once again.
‐Who has a $4 million value?
‐$4 million.
He probably wants you to drink
that whole bottle of wine.
‐$4 million valuation.
‐Yep.
And that's because
your sales are huge!
‐Yes!
‐Drum roll.
We've sold $1.4 million
in 10 months!
‐Oh! I'll drink to that!
‐What?! What?!
‐Ohh!
‐Ohh! Yeah!
How the beep
is that possible?
I was doing
a little bit of social media,
and I put out a tweet
that said,
"You need to get
a Guzzle Buddy
to make it through
the next presidential debate."
‐Ah!
‐[ Laughs ]
But what happened was
a big social‐media place
that had millions
of followers picked up on it,
took
some of the little videos
and pictures
that we had been making,
and put it out
to their 14 million viewers.
And the next thing you know...
‐Wow.
Bam!
We sold out ‐‐
Yep, we sold out in three days.
How much money did you make
on that in profits?
In profits?
$320,000.
‐Whoa!
‐Wow!
‐Yeah!
What does one cost?
Well, one costs
the manufacturer $3.12.
And we sell them
for $24.99.
‐Whoa!
‐Wow!
So you sell one wine glass,
essentially...
Yes.
...for $24.99.
‐That's amazing.
What's your history, though,
in products?
Well, I was a geologist for
a couple years until I was ‐‐
What happened?
Well, I was blessed
by having twin girls
and became a stay‐at‐home mom
for the last 14 years.
How did you meet Randy?
This is
my brother‐in‐law.
I grew up on a dairy farm,
and I got up at 4:00 in
the morning and I milked cows ‐‐
and they never go on vacation,
by the way.
I also
went to dental school.
You're a dentist?
Yes, so I was a dentist
for 20 years.
Then I had a hand surgery, and I
had to retire from dentistry.
So that was fairly devastating.
‐Oh.
I mean,
I didn't know what to do.
And then Jennifer called me
one day and said,
"Hey, we need to find
this wine‐bottle glass."
And the rest is history.
I predict everybody up here
loves you guys,
but I predict nobody is gonna
give you $400,000 for 10%.
That's over 10 times
the best‐case scenario
of what you'll make.
We have sold the $1.4 million
in 10 months in just the wine.
We just came out
with the beer,
and we project that it's going
to do the same as it did ‐‐
you know,
as the wine has done.
So we're valuating that ‐‐
I didn't like it
with the beer.
It ‐‐
Because it goes too slowly.
Right.
You know, when you guzzle it,
you're like, "Boom!"
Cuban:
Let me just tell you this.
You're celebrating ‐‐ When
the Mavs win the championship,
you're drinking
out of the bottle, right?
Right.
When you see somebody drinking
out of the bottle,
that gets in the way.
Unless they want
the attention.
From that?
‐Yes!
‐Absolutely!
If you're drinking this
in your house,
chances are
you have a problem.
‐Guys. Guys.
‐I'm out.
You know what, the worst thing
an entrepreneur can do
is talk theory.
‐Mark's out.
‐What happened?
‐He's out.
‐Mark is out, Daymond.
‐Why?
‐I'm out.
‐Because he doesn't want
to give them $400,000.
John: You know what,
I love the numbers.
That's like
talking dirty to me.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Here is my thing.
This is a space
that some other Sharks here
would be way more valuable in
regards to a strategic partner.
It's not for me.
I'm out.
‐Well, thank you.
‐Okay, thank you.
There's one thing I've learned
over the past several years.
‐Only one?
‐No. Many.
[ Laughter ]
700 or so products later,
it's very fascinating
to me ‐‐
America drinks.
‐No! I don't believe it!
‐Yes!
So I get
how you've done $1.4 million.
But that is a staggering,
crazy, huge number.
Will you be able
to sustain that?
That's my big question.
It went viral in October,
and we were thinking
the same thing ‐‐
"Is this going to kind
of fizzle out at the new year?"
But we've continued
to sell.
Jennifer, as I travel around
the country, people say to me,
"If I could only invent
a better mouse trap..."
‐Yes.
‐[ Chuckles ]
And I always say to them,
"There's no such thing
as a better mouse trap.
It's all about execution."
‐Sure.
And this big, fancy answer.
And guess what, I'm wrong.
It's a better mouse trap.
It's cool.
You're a dentist, a mom.
And here you are
on "Shark Tank."
Incredible!
You've done everything right,
except one thing.
What's that?
When you start asking
for $400,000 for 10%,
how do we get behind that?
Like, if you would have asked
for a couple hundred thousand,
everybody here would have said,
"Love them! I'm in!"
At $400,000 for 10%, you've got
to have backend operations.
This is a real ‐‐
even for the Sharks,
we think twice
before putting in $400,000.
‐Sure.
‐I can't see it.
I'm out.
I'm choking on the $400,000
for 10%, at any percent.
There's no way in the world
I'm writing a check
for $400,000 for this.
It just ain't gonna happen.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you. Appreciate it.
I'm the only one left.
First and foremost,
I go with my gut.
And my gut tells me
you're good, honest people.
I like you.
‐Thank you.
‐Uh‐oh.
‐Don't do it, Lori.
$1.4 million in sales.
That's staggering
in 10 months.
I agree with my fellow Sharks.
It's a crazy valuation.
I mean,
this is a novelty gift.
So I'm gonna give you
an opportunity
to convince me
why I should go in,
and I'm gonna ask you
to be creative
with the valuation
that everybody else stepped on.
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Lori's interested
in Randy and Jennifer's novelty
glass company, Guzzle Buddy.
I'm gonna give you
an opportunity
to convince me
why I should go in,
and I'm gonna ask you
to be creative
with the valuation
that everybody else stepped on.
Because at $400,000 for 10%,
I will not give you a deal.
You know, I mean,
I feel so strongly
because of the way we have
continued to have sales.
I was worried
after the first of the year.
I was like,
"What's gonna happen?"
A lot of talking.
No numbers.
[ Chuckles ]
I mean, what do you think
for numbers, Jennifer?
Um...
I mean, you had a number
that you would go to
when you came in.
‐Yeah.
You knew we'd negotiate it.
‐Just be honest.
♪♪
$400,000 for 20%.
I'll do it at 25%
if you do it right now.
Keep going.
You still have more time.
I'll $400,000 now for 25%
if you do it right now.
‐$400,000 ‐‐
‐25%?!
Wait. Wait. Wait.
I will do the $400,000
as a line of credit.
So no line of credit
versus line of credit.
I will do the $400,000
line of credit ‐‐ 20%.
The cows
need to be milked!
‐Done deal!
‐Let's get it done.
[ All cheer ]
‐Hey!
Yeah!
Congrats.
I love you guys!
Thank you.
We love you, too!
That was utterly awesome.
That's how we do it, baby.
Yeah, baby!
‐Bye!
‐Cheers!
‐Cheers! Whoo!
‐Congrats. Congrats.
‐Thank you, Lori. I love it.
Whoo! Whoo!
Cheers!
Yeah, baby!
Yeah!
Whoo‐hoo‐hoo‐hoo!
Rothfus: I think Daymond is ‐‐
brings a lot to Guzzle Buddy.
For one thing, he is a master
at building a brand,
and that's
what we want to do.
We don't want to be
a one‐product wonder.
We want to be a brand,
and I think that ‐‐
I think we nailed it
with Daymond.
Daymond, you just bought
a glass on top of a bottle.
[ Laughter ]
The Shark Tank's going crazy.
♪♪